über par honorierte den überglücklichen
zu schreiben ist eigentlich der falsche
modus so gewöhnlich zu sachlich und vor
allem viel zu beengt lachen und weinen
das sind die beiden richtigen monique
für diesen film denn das passiert wenn
man diesen film sieht
ein beispiel gefällig
wie bei die überglücklichen sachlich zu
schreiben das kommt einem ein bisschen
so vor als würde man ihn nach seinen
fahrschein fragen genau wie seine beiden
hauptfiguren gelingt es dem film das
einem solche regeln willkürlich und
absurd fach die überglücklichen erzählt
die geschichte von beatrice donatella
die sich als patientinnen in einer
psychiatrie kennenlernen
die bipolare wer tritt schon länger dort
und weiß mit einer hochnäsigen art die
patientinnen und das personal zu werfen
es kommt wie es kommen muss kaum hat der
pritsche donatella als komplizin erobert
brechen die beiden aus unterwegs
begegnet ihnen ihr jeweiliges lebens
chaos wieder bei dem sie einander
abwechselnd helfen und bekämpfen und
lachen und weinen
das färbt auch auf den zuschauer ab das
ist paolo virzi gelingt die gefühle
seiner figuren so direkt zu
transportieren war nicht abzusehen
sein letzter film die süße gier wollte
unbedingt kapitalismus und
gesellschaftskritisch sein war dabei
aber vor allem tc haft dafür dass es
diesmal besser klappt darf er sich bei
seinen beiden hauptdarstellerinnen
bedanken
valeria bruni tedeschi und micaela
ramazotti spielen beide so wahnsinnig
gut ohne angst vor den lauten vulgären
oder grillen und ohne ins parodistische
abzudriften
am ende des films gibt man beide für
ihre durchgedreht haid die
überglücklichen ist glaubwürdig albern
und glaubwürdig schlimm
er lacht über seine figuren aber nicht
von oben herab und ist dabei
einfühlsamen aber trotzdem nicht gelacht
das einzige was dem film im weg stehen
könnte sind zu hohe erwartungen
[Musik]